et avec nous pour ce club il serait art
bonjour Yves merci d'être avec nous
la rédaction du Figaro je me disais
Aulas bonjour Jean-Baptiste journaliste
politique à Libération et Alex tu vas
rejoindre on va parler des mobilisations
du 1er mai à Nice qui ont réuni plus de
monde qu'elle a coutumée des Français
toujours mobilisés contre la réforme des
retraites mais que peuvent désormais
faire les syndicats quels sont leurs
marges de manoeuvre et puis on vous le
dirait et puis on reviendra sur les
violences qui ont aimé certains cortèges
dans plusieurs villes du pays pas de
défilé pour Marine Le Pen mais un
bancaire républicain au Havre baptisé
faite de la nation dans la ville
d'Édouard Philippe Marine Le Pen avait
une cible Emmanuel Macron on va en
parler mais d'abord on regarde
l'actualité dans nos régions
et l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
parler de ces défilés du premier mai on
va à Marseille on retrouve les hauts
purgate bonjour Léo merci d'être avec
nous président et directeur éditorial du
Journal La Marseillaise Léo comment
s'est passé ce 1er mai chez vous à
Marseille
elle s'est passé de la meilleure des
manières pour les syndicats puisque il y
avait une affluence probablement
jamais vu depuis une vingtaine d'années
pour un 1er mai plus de 200 000 selon
les syndicats dans nos trois
départements provençaux les
Bouches-du-Rhône le Vaucluse et le Var
on en rend d'ailleurs très largement
compte dans nos pages aujourd'hui et
puis c'est à souligné parce que ça n'est
pas le cas sur tout le territoire
national ces cortège se sont déroulés
dans une ambiance apaisée dans une
ambiance
encadrée par des services d'ordre des
syndicats qui n'ont pas été
débordés et donc on a vu des cortèges
avec beaucoup de familles avec de la
colère mais aussi de la joie d'être
ensemble
et
il y a chez vous à Marseille
les
alors dans d'autres grandes villes Paris
Lyon n’entraîne les cortèges ont été
éveillés de violences
mais d'abord parce que il y a ici des
services d'ordre de syndicats qui sont
rompus à l'exercice des organisations
qui sont probablement fortes et qui sont
des composantes indispensables de la
démocratie sociale qui savent organiser
comme ils le font ces cortèges peut-être
aussi que dans nos départements très
touchés par la pauvreté il y a une
sociologie un petit peu différente qui
fait que le monde du travail qui
s'exprime et bien est en effet plus
composé de travailleurs que de
perturbateurs comment on a pu le voir en
couronne parisienne un dernier mois avec
vous Léo quelles sont les perspectives
aujourd'hui pour les syndicats que
disent-ils du côté de Marseille
prochaine mobilisation des grèves
alors en effet on a interrogé les
manifestants sur les suites qu'ils
imaginaient à ce mouvement certains
évoquent la deuxième tentative de
référendum d'initiative partagée sur
laquelle devra se prononcer dans les
tous prochains jours le Conseil
constitutionnel et puis beaucoup
d'autres appellent à une journée de
grève et de manifestations le 6 le 6 mai
il va y avoir une inter syndicale au
plan national aujourd'hui qui sera
décliné dans nos départements et nous
verrons si cette interfe syndicale
solide qui tient depuis maintenant
plusieurs mois va tenir à nouveau et
prendre des initiatives communes en tout
cas forte de se succès d'affluence
d'hier
l'intersyndicale devra se prononcer sur
les moyens de faire payer le
gouvernement et le président de la
République qui avait fait le pari et
bien de passer à autre chose de tourner
la page et on le voit très nettement le
monde du travail mobilisé lui a décidé
de ne pas tourner la page merci les
d'avoir été avec nous pendant parlé de
ce 1er mai du côté de Marseille et de la
Provence marée haute c'est le titre que
vous avez choisi aujourd'hui en Une de
La Marseillaise merci beaucoup Léo
purgett Léo le disait beaucoup de monde
à Marseille beaucoup de monde dans
plusieurs villes de France près de
800000 c'est plus qu'un 1er mai
traditionnel selon les chiffres du
ministère de l'Intérieur plus de 2
millions selon la CGT les syndicats
misés sur une journée historique est-ce
que le pari est réussi Jean-Baptiste
quand on voit la multiplication par
rapport au taux de présence de de l'an
dernier effectivement c'est un succès ah
c'est pas forcément historique pas
forcément un record mais il y a
clairement à succès on avait
l'impression que c'était presque une 13e
ou 14e journée de mobilisation nationale
contre contre la réforme des retraites
plus qu'un premier maître additionnel
donc le message envoyé qui a toujours
des centaines de milliers de personnes
mobilisées contre cette réforme des
retraites il est passé dans tous les cas
aussi pour les syndicats oui c'est à
Paris réussi oui bien sûr ce qui est
maintenant ce qui est intéressant c'est
ce qui va se passer à l'avenir est-ce
que le front syndical va rester unis ou
au contraire est-ce que le gouvernement
qui mise là-dessus je pense va réussir à
le diviser c'est ça c'est l'enjeu
mais c'est vrai que c'était pas évident
que il réussisse cette journée qui a été
un peu ternie par les violences parce
que on parle beaucoup de cela et un peu
moins de la mobilisation mais c'est vrai
qu'ils ont réussi à mobiliser et c'était
pas évident parce que il y a quand même
une fatigue depuis trois mois que ça ça
dure et puis cette détermination alors
je pense que le bras de fer dont on
parle tant n'est pas terminé et que le
gouvernement a quand même pas mal de
soucis à se faire ça on est loin de
l'essoufflement sur lequel mise exécutif
après ça dépend ce que l'on entend par
essoufflement si c'est d'imaginer un
mouvement national qui vise à ce que il
y a un retrait de la réforme clairement
c'est pas ce qui s'est passé on voit que
le Conseil constitutionnel sans doute
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui va rejeter le la
demande de référendum populaire du du de
la gauche
la décision est attendue quelque part
d'un point de vue institutionnel la
récréation enfin a été sifflé c'est
c'est fini ce qui veut pas dire qu'il va
pas continuer à feuilletonner vous avez
le 8 juin vous avez cette proposition de
loi du groupe liotte à l'assemblée qui
pourrait montrer qu'il y a une majorité
parlementaire contre cette réforme des
retraites même si ça aucune chance de
prospérer avec le marécage parlementaire
que serait les navettes avec le Sénat et
le gouvernement
ce serait catastrophique au niveau
mbolique pour le gouvernement de montrer
qu'il y a une majorité de par le mode de
députés contre mais voilà ça il y a ce
il y a ce feuilleton qui va continuer et
même de même dans un an un an et un jour
après la promulgation du texte certains
peuvent toujours relancer un projet de
référendum mais même s'il est rejeté
demain par contre c'est constitution de
constitutionnel donc il y a quand même
ce poison qui qui va continuer et puis
c'est aussi les enchères que vont faire
monter les syndicats pour revenir à la
table des négociations avec le
gouvernement ça aussi ça va coûter cher
ouais les syndicats qui mise
effectivement beaucoup hein sur ce 8
juin et cette proposition là
d'abrogation de la réforme des retraites
pour vous elle peut passer ils ont
raison de miser là dessus non ça
m'étonnerait qu'elle passe sincèrement
ça m'étonnerait mais je pense que
effectivement maintenant on est passé
peut-être à l'accompagnement de la
réforme des retraites et là ils vont
faire payer cher les syndicats en plus
le gouvernement va pas avoir trop le
choix parce qu'il a intérêt à ce que ça
cesse et les enchères vont être très
hautes je pense que on va se réveiller
un jour en se disant que cette réforme
des retraites a peut-être été plus cher
que les économies qui va nous qu'elle
aurait dû susciter non je plaisante mais
c'est quand même un des problèmes
majeurs et d'ailleurs c'est ce que notre
même si j'ai pas une grande confiance
dans les agences de notation qui sont
d'une versatilité totale mais c'est ce
qu'elle note l'agence Fitch
la semaine dernière qui qui montrait que
cette réforme qui aurait dû Nort au
contraire conforté la note française et
bien la dégradé
voilà non ça va être intéressant je
pense que c'est déterminant parce que le
conflit est va bien au-delà de la
réforme de la seule réforme des
retraites et maintenant ce qui est en
jeu c'est la confiance
et même au-delà de la confiance c'est la
popularité du président de la République
quand même sérieusement entamé je ne
crois pas que dans l'histoire de la 5e
République il y a un tel mouvement de
détestation et de haine qui se soit
exprimée ainsi et pourquoi parce que
contrairement à ces deux prédécesseurs
qui eux aussi ont essuyé des rejets qui
sont violents ils se sont fait éjecter
de leur siège et ils ont été battus ils
n'ont pas pu faire un deuxième mandat
alors que là le président actuel fait un
deuxième mandat et qu'on se dit que ça
va encore durer pendant quatre ans et
que si c'est dans des conditions
sociales dans un climat aussi détestable
ça risque d'être quand même assez
compliqué même si dans le cas d'Emmanuel
Macron on voit que quand on regarde les
études d'opinion RC est une détestation
énorme de sa personne mais son socle son
noyau dur de entre 24 28% selon les
instituts de sondage et quand même
toujours là et c'est vrai que ça
correspond peu au pro à son score de
premier tour de 2022 donc les
macronistes sera sur beaucoup avec ce
chiffre là en disant que quelque part le
noyau est encore là et que à partir de
ce noyau il pourront rebâtir et
d'ailleurs c'est ce que fait Emmanuel
Macron en essayant de multiplier un peu
les déplacements comme ça c'est de se
dire que au bout d'un moment ils vont
finir par retrouver un lien avec une
population qui certes n'aime pas la
réforme des retraites mais qui peut-être
aime encore moins le bazar le blocage il
y a un petit peu de cynisme là-dedans
aussi ça ça empêche pas mais voilà c'est
un peu la stratégie qui qui est en
oeuvre actuellement et on va reparler de
la suite mais on va revenir sur ce qui
s'est passé hier parce que vous le
disiez les cortèges ce sont bien passés
dans la plupart des villes mais il y a
eu des violences dans certaines villes
Alex violence et affrontement entre
casseurs et forge de l'ordre mais oui
avec un bilan assez lourd il y a eu 108
blessés chez les policiers et les
gendarmes 200 chez les manifestants et 2
91 personnes ont été interpellés des
violences notamment en mars du cortège
parisien très tôt dans l'après-midi dès
le début de la manifestation plusieurs
centaines de Black Blocs ce sont
immiscés à l'avant du cortège ils ont
notamment dégradé des agences bancaires
et immobilières ils ont jeté des
projectiles sur les forces de l'ordre et
un policier a été brûlé au visage et au
bras par un cocktail Molotov son
pronostic vital n'est pas engagée à Lyon
également un millier de casseurs étaient
présents des voitures ont été incendiées
sur le parcours des supérettes ont été
pillées si manifestants et 16 policiers
blessés dont un CRS grièvement et puis à
Nantes des affrontements ont éclaté en
début d'après-midi au niveau de la
préfecture un début d'incendie de la
préfecture a même ces mêmes produits il
y a après midi à Nantes et puis un
gendarme et quatre manifestants ont été
transportés à l'hôpital dont un
manifestant qui a été sévèrement touché
à la main on peut citer également les
villes de Rennes Angers et Bordeaux dans
lesquels il y a eu des violences en
marge des cortèges et
Alex face à ces violences il y a eu des
réactions politiques oui il a commencé
par la première ministre Elisabeth borne
elle le reconnaît en dans de nombreuses
villes de France ce premier mai a été un
moment de mobilisation et d'engagement
responsable mais les scènes de violence
en marge des cortèges en sont d'autant
plus inacceptable soutien de la première
ministre aux forces de l'ordre le
ministre de l'Intérieur général de
Darmanin a souhaité également réagir on
l'écoute
absolument pas normal en République que
des policiers que des gendarmes
connaissaient sapeurs-pompiers se fasse
prendre à parti se faire jeter les côtés
motophe ou des pavés si je prends
l'exemple de Paris c'est 19 policiers
gendarmes sont envoyés aujourd'hui à
l'hôpital évidemment nous pensons nous
pensons à alors à droite et au
rassemblement national les réactions ne
se sont pas faites attendre face à ces
violences selon Marine Le Pen je la cite
nous ne sommes plus face à des violences
mais face à des tentatives d'assassinat
contre les forces de l'ordre quand aux
incendies d'habitation et bien ils
doivent être traduits devant la cour
d'assises pour le patron du parti
républicains avec ce type transformer
nos forces de l'ordre en torche humaine
et abattre la République voilà ce que
voulait les Black Blocs présents en
nombre il y a après-midi à Paris tout
elle est groupuscules d'extrême gauche
violents doivent être dissout selon
l'exiotiques et puis le président du
groupe LR au Sénat Bruno Retailleau a
lui aussi réagi je le cite la haine et
les violences dont font l'objet nos
forces de l'ordre en marge des
manifestations de ce 1er mai sont
inadmissibles combien de temps faudra
encore compter pour mettre un terme à ce
spectacle de des civilisations en
revanche les réactions à gauche face à
ces violences étaient un petit peu plus
rares sont
et gendarmes qui ont été blessés hier
500 40 interpellations avant de vous
faire réagir on va écouter un sénateur
de gauche justement sénateur socialise
Jérôme du Rhin il était hier en
immersion dans le cortège parisien en
immersion avec la brave m pour mieux
comprendre la stratégie du maintien de
l'ordre Jonathan dupréas et Fabien
Ricard ont suivi on écoute
ça c'est ce qui c'est ce qui a été
envoyé
dans ce qui est intéressant pour moi là
c'est de voir comment à la fois il y a
la dimension de protection de la
manifestation syndicale et comment les
unités s'intéressent à tout ce qui se
passe autour et tous les les violences
opportunistes toutes les violences
opportunistes qui se
produisent à la faveur du cortège quoi
et je crois qu'ils essayent
effectivement de maintenir la
possibilité pour le cortège je crois le
verset on essayant de d'éviter que les
dégâts soient trop importants
du prix et Fabien Ricard pour un
reportage de Fabien Ricard sur la
stratégie du maintien de l'ordre sur le
maintien de l'ordre qui sera diffusé
prochainement sur notre antenne est-ce
que les violences qu'on a vu et les
chiffres donnés par Gérald Darmanin sur
le nombre de forces de l'ordre BLC ça
peut nuire au mouvement ça peut
affaiblir les opposants
oui je pense que c'est pas c'est pas une
effectivement c'est pas mais enfin faut
pas que le gouvernement compte sur le
pourrissement par la violence du
mouvement je crois que c'est pas ça je
pense que c'est
évidemment piloter ni par le
gouvernement ni par les forces
syndicales elle n'y est pas intérêt ce
qui est plus grave c'est de savoir que
il y a énormément de de force exogène
d'ailleurs qui viennent de l'étranger
qui se mêlent à cette espèce de
d'international de la violence qui
se moque complètement d'ailleurs de la
réforme des retraites ou de la politique
du gouvernement pour saccager là il y a
une espèce de résurgence d'une d'une
haine anti anti-républicaine
anti-démocratique aussi qui ferait bien
d'être observé de très près parce que
ils étaient exceptionnellement très
nombreux hier notamment à Paris encore
plus nombreux je crois qu'en 2018 quand
il y avait eu déjà les exploits de
Monsieur là vous vous souvenez c'était
l'année de Benalla
ou déjà il y avait eu énormément
d'exactions donc là c'est encore plus
inquiétant je trouve donc les forces de
l'ordre et le gouvernement serait bien
inspirés de regarder ça comme le lait
sur le feu de très près parce que c'est
assez inquiétant après voilà je pense
qu'il faut faire attention aussi aux
prismes avec lequel on regarde ces
événements là
on parle de est-ce qu'on parle de
casseurs ou est-ce qu'on parle de de
manifestants on peut pas résumer des
manifestations au comportement de
certains casseurs c'est de la même
manière qu'on peut pas on peut pas
résumer le maintien de l'ordre à
certaines violences policières qu'on va
tourner en boucle de manière très ciblée
aussi sur les réseaux sociaux voilà donc
ça ça a pas forcément de sens comme le
disait Yves je crois que le miser sur le
pourrissement de manière générale qui
est une forme de pourrissement qui
nuisent au mouvement des retraites c'est
un calcul qui est assez dangereux dans
le sens où quand vous avez ce niveau de
tension vous avez des dérapages vous
avez des drames qui peuvent arriver dans
qui peuvent aussi inflamer ou impacter
différemment la lecture qu'on aura le
qu'on aura l'opinion publique vous
pouvez avoir des victimes dans les
manifestants aussi des gens qui n'ont
qui n'est pas venus là pour casser ça
peut aussi ça peut aussi devenir des
symboles qui
comment dire qui de suicide une colère
aussi dans le reste dans le reste de la
population on peut faire attention à ça
il faut aussi faire attention à l'image
qui est donné de la France et du
maintien de l'ordre à l'international
vous avez au niveau des Nations Unies
des communes des comités des commissions
sur les droits de l'homme qui commence à
poser des questions sur le maintien de
l'ordre d'enfance la façon avec laquelle
les manifestations sont encadrées au
niveau de l'image de la France au niveau
international c'est pas forcément génial
on l'a vu parce qu'effectivement il y a
des questions et des critiques sur la
stratégie du maintien de l'ordre on a vu
ce sénateur socialiste Jérôme du Rhin
que nos reporters ont suivi montrer ce
marteau reçu par les forces de l'ordre
je pense qu'il n'était pas critique du
tout hein il était surpris de la
violence parce que autant que je sache
c'est un sénateur socialiste qui est
hostile à
donc mais il a été quand même assez
subjugué enfin pas subjugué pardon
surpris par la violence il pensait pas
que c'était c'est pas c'est pas simple
le maintien de l'ordre on sait qu'ils
ont abandonné certains pratiques qui
avaient fait beaucoup jaser pendant la
la le mouvement des gilets jaunes
notamment l'histoire de la nasse mais
moi je les ai vus à l'oeuvre hier là
c'est quand même compliqué
ils prennent des risques importants ils
sont en première ligne et c'est pas une
partie de plaisir là c'est pas c'est pas
de l'intimidation c'est c'est vraiment
des ils ont en face d'eux des gens tout
à fait déterminés à cassé et c'est
important du coup que les parlementaires
aïe
l'exemple de ce sénateur il devrait
multiplier par 10 par 15 pour que les
politiques se rendent compte un peu de
la difficulté de maintenir l'ordre dans
ces conditions là est-ce que ce qui
s'est passé hier ça ça peut être le
risque d'une radicalisation du mouvement
qui va se radicaliser au fur et à mesure
qu'il s'affaiblit en nombre
ce qu'on a vu hier c'est qu'il y a des
casseurs il y a des manifestants les
casseurs sont une minorité on voit que
les cortèges syndicaux ont quand même
des services d'ordre plutôt bien
organisés que de l'immense majorité des
manifestants ce qu'on porte extrêmement
bien il y a pas il y a pas de sujet
faudrait pas non plus comme on arrive à
remettre en cause le droit de manifester
qu'un liberté constitutionnelle quand
même mais ça peut fait bien le mouvement
oui c'est à dire que ça peut ça peut
enfin
ce sont les idiots utiles du
gouvernement
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup je
pense de manifestants qui sont là pour
manifester contre l'air traite qui
se poseraient peut-être des questions et
puis il y a peut-être certaines
centrales syndicales qui n'ont pas du
tout envie de s'associer à ce genre de
de bazar si vous voulez
revoir mais je pense que alors là pour
le coup le gouvernement peut être
essayer de jouer là-dessus pour jouer la
négociation justement c'est toujours
c'est pas une bonne une bonne chose
évidemment bien sûr c'est aujourd'hui la
reprise des débats parlementaires après
deux semaines de pause au Parlement
reprise risquées pour l'exécutif
Jean-Baptiste
parce que là l'Assemblée nationale ça
commence avec ce qu'on appelle une
semaine de contrôle donc c'est des
petits débats comme ça pour pas trop qui
ont pas trop d'enjeux oui après là c'est
c'est risqué dans la mesure où
l'exécutif est exactement dans la
position dans laquelle il est depuis un
an c'est à dire de devoir négocier texte
par textes de pas avoir de majorité et
avec le niveau de détestation
issue de des débats sur la réforme des
retraites l'idée que n'importe quel
texte un peu ambitieux un peu clivant
politiquement ne peut plus passer
aujourd'hui sans sans article 49-3
sachant que la dernière fois la motion
de censurée est passée à nouveau on voit
l'espèce de blocage dans laquelle dans
lequel se trouve exécutif à pouvoir ni
remanier ni dissoudre c'est une forme
d'immobilisme de 200 sur latente comme
le dit très bien le sénateur François
Patriat c'est la bonne c'est l'exact
expression pour des vents de la
situation pour définir la situation dans
laquelle se trouve l'exécutif
c'est là on va voir la maîtrise de la
maestria de Madame borne parce que là
pour le coup elle joue peut-être son
avenir
on sait que jusqu'au 14 juillet c'est
elle qui doit essayer de trouver un
nouvel élan un nouveau souffle
si elle n'arrive pas à trouver un nouvel
an un nouvel élan un nouveau souffle ça
veut dire qu'elle arrive à trouver des
alliés à l'intérieur de l'Assemblée
nationale au cas par cas de calmer un
peu et d'apaiser le climat c'est à elle
de jouer on sait que
c'est une technicienne donc elle n'est
pas toujours dans le sourire et
la caresse c'est ce puis dire
démocratique donc on va voir si il
parvient quand même on va parler d'une
des principales opposants de ce
gouvernement c'est Marine Le Pen qui a
renoué hier avec la tradition du 1er mai
mais pour le rassemblement national fini
Jeanne d'Arc place à la fête de la
nation et elle avait choisi Le Havre la
ville d'Edouard Philippe dans un
discours aux allures de campagne
présidentielle Marine Le Pen avait une
cible Emmanuel Macron
contester il a amené le pays à une crise
institutionnelle et d'une crise
institutionnelle à une impasse politique
il ne faudrait pas que son entêtement
puérile fasse basculer le pays dans le
désordre et le chaos
symbole terrible de l'impuissance
politique l'État ne parvient plus à
organiser la visite d'un monarque d'une
nation ami
les ministres n'arrivent plus à se
déplacer pour l'inauguration du moindre
rond-point
mais quand sera-t-il des JO qui
devraient être une grande fête nationale
et sportive faut-il s'attendre encore à
une nouvelle humiliation
Emmanuel Macron voulait mettre le pays
en marche il l'a mis en panne
voilà la cible c'était Emmanuel Macron
c'était un discours de campagne
présidentielle
Ivy R qui a fait Marine Le Pen
j'ai pas très bien qui ça peut toucher
si vous voulez parce que c'est quand
même en cercle fermé
au Havre par définition il y a que des
des soutiens à Madame Le Pen alors je
sais que elle avait l'ambition de de
montrer que son opposant à venir en 2027
ça serait Édouard Philippe
parce que c'est une ville ouvrière et
qu'elle voulait s'adresser à la France
qui travaille donc ça a pas le même
impact si vous voulez que les discours
qu'elle pouvait faire à l'époque place
de l'Opéra à Paris qui était très
attendu ou qui était ouvert par
définition à tous ceux qui voulaient
aller les écouter donc je suis pas
persuadé que ça soit la meilleure des la
meilleure des techniques mais bon elle a
sans doute ses raisons
faut voir aller à l'épreuve des années
elle voulait elle avait choisi Le Havre
ville ouvrière elle voulait parler au
travailleur finalement elle a très peu
parlé du pouvoir d'achat de l'inflation
dans son discours comme on peut le
comprendre Jean-Baptiste en fait Marine
Le Pen est en train d'inventer la
campagne électorale de 5 ans c'est c'est
comme du jamais vu parce qu'elle dit que
elle est candidate jusqu'à preuve
qu'elle dise qu'elle ne l'est pas euh
bah il y a quand même une forme
d'essoufflement c'est quand même
difficile de de gérer son temps quand il
n'y a pas non plus stratégie de rareté
de de sa part elle est elle est présente
depuis un an on comprend qu'elle Valette
pendant pendant les quatre prochaines
années le temps d'avancer des
propositions fatalement on peut pas
arriver tout de suite non plus puisque
c'est plutôt un temps de campagne en
général dans lesquels on arrive avec un
programme un peu plus un peu plus
charpenté donc elle est dans cette
stratégie de quelque part de de surplomb
un peu attentiste à essayer d'engranger
la colère sur tous les sujets en faisant
bien garde à ne rien proposer parce que
si regardez hier sur dans son discours
la réforme des retraites et de n'en
parle qu'une seule fois de manière quand
même assez assez brève quasiment pas
elle a tourné la page elle le pouvoir
d'achat c'est pas dans quel que l'on n'a
pas c'est qu'elle a intérêt à pas y
mettre à pied parce que comment comment
elle va justifier le fait de d'abroger
la réforme actuelle comment elle va
équilibrer les comptes comment sur
l'inflation elle va apporter des des
réponses tous ces sujets là dès qu'elle
commence à découvrir un peu on les ces
opposants commencent à décortiquer ce
qu'elle propose montrer que c'est
souvent inepte d'un point de vue
économique et donc dans ces cas-là elle
perd des points de crédibilité qu'elle
essaye de qu'elle essaie de construire
donc c'est pas tellement étonnant
qu'elle met pas tellement de
propositions sur l'inflation au pouvoir
d'achat en revanche elle a parlé
d'immigration notamment la fustigé
l'Union européenne sur la question de
l'immigration elle en a profité pour
lancer sa campagne des européennes
c'est assez attendu tout ça ce qui était
intéressant c'est que justement Le Pen
elle avait fait sa campagne électorale
pour la présidentielle sur les thèmes
économiques sur le pouvoir d'achat sur
ces sujets là et un peu moins sur les
sujets régaliens contrairement à ce
qu'elle faisait d'habitude bon là elle
revient au sujet régalien il y a rien de
surprenant bien sur l'immigration en
plus comme le gouvernement est quand
même dans une situation pour le moins
flou sur ce sujet on sait pas ce qu'ils
vont faire entre madame Borg qui dit que
c'est pas le moment et Monsieur
Macron qui dit que c'est une de ses
priorités on comprend plus rien elle
était un peu sortie de ces thèmes
notamment pendant la campagne alors elle
y revient parce que effectivement je
suis assez d'accord elle est pas si vous
voulez toutes les propositions qu'elle
peut faire en termes économique pour
contrer la vie chère pour
éventuellement une crise économique qui
pourrait se profiler elle est pas du
tout armée pour ça elle a jamais eu une
une proposition qui soit à la hauteur
des enjeux donc elle mission à la
campagne européenne et sur ce thème de
l'immigration ce qui est sûr c'est que
comme le disait il y a une gêne de la
majorité actuelle qui n'a pas de
majorité pour faire passer le texte
qu'il voulait entre davantage de titres
de séjour pour les médias en tension et
en même temps il a durcissement des de
la reconduite à la frontière des
personnes en situation irrégulières donc
elle elle voit bien qu'il y a une gêne
sur ce sujet là elle va elle va y aller
elle va appuyer dessus ça c'est ça c'est
évident que ça va ça va se passer dans
les dans les prochaines
c'est d'avoir en face d'elle un
gouvernement qui veut s'emparer de
l'immigration et qu'il n'y arrive pas
parce qu'il est empêché de le faire pour
des raisons de majorité parlementaire
c'est ce serait comment dire ce serait
presque une faute stratégique de sa part
de pas on va appuyer dessus puis sur les
européennes c'est effectivement un thème
qui est extrêmement porteur aussi pour
pour le rassemblement national un des
rares scrutins à la proportionnelle dans
voilà dans les dans les dans les
élections françaises au niveau national
donc évidemment c'est un moment
extrêmement fort pour pour cranter sans
doute une place de premier partie assez
échéance là elle est obligé de à mon
avis effectivement de cranter là-dessus
parce que il va y avoir la rivalité de
Éric Zemmour probablement qui lui alors
là elle repasse
va pas se faire prier pour aller sur ces
sujets là donc elle a intérêt dès
maintenant à mettre la barre assez haut
sur la
fin assez originale de la part de Marine
Le Pen en fait
une sorte de bancaire
vous voulez c'est que bon elle touche
pas beaucoup de monde dans ce cadre-là
elle ne fait que que davantage persuadé
ce qu'ils le sont déjà donc c'est c'est
faut voir
ce qu'elle a fait hein donc je peux pas
juger
oui les images
on a montré que elle a montré elle a
réussi à montrer qu'elle était très
populaire mais c'est au sein des siens
donc ça va beaucoup plus loin
un petit risque de de lassitude aussi
parce que quand on se positionne que
candidate son camp pendant 5 ans il y a
un moment on va quand même intérêt à
feuilletonner tout ça et raconter des
choses que sinon il y a quand même un
risque de lassitude et on a vu que la
dernière fois Eric Zemmour a déjà failli
lui la doubler au dernier moment qui dit
qu'il y aura pas quelqu'un d'autre qui
va arriver dans ce laps de temps
on reparle du 1er mai c'est évidemment
la Une de beaucoup de nos Cotillard
région de ce matin
[Musique]
et Alex après régional revient beaucoup
sur le 1er mai une journée du 1er mai
marquée par deux symboles d'abord le
muguet symbole de la fête du Travail et
puis les casseroles symboles de
l'incontestation contre la réforme des
retraites c'est à la une du béry
républicain une réforme des retraites
qui a regonflé cette journée du premier
mai de virgule 3 millions de
participants dans la rue selon la CGT
800 000 selon le ministère de
l'intérieur avec dans certaines villes
démobilisations historiques pour un 1er
mai c'était le cas par exemple à Pau ou
8000 personnes ont défilé c'était la Une
de La République des Pyrénées et dans
les cortèges il y avait forcément du
dépit et de la colère puisque la réforme
des retraites va être appliquée c'est à
la Une de l'Union une amertume qui se
faisait sentir notamment chez les
manifestants à Reims des manifestants
qui est pour certains ont voté Emmanuel
Macron au second tour de la
présidentielle pour faire barrage à
Marine Le Pen mais certains le
regrettent je vais en citer un si en
2027 il faut encore voter utile pour la
droite contre l'extrême droite ce sera
sans moi il y avait de la colère hier
dans les cortèges il y avait de la
violence en marge des défilés une
journée soit haute tension résume
Nice-Matin à feu et à cran titre le
journal Le Progrès de Lyon car à Lyon et
bien la manifestation a été
particulerturbée par des milliers de
Black Blocs avec des voitures incendiées
des supérettes pillées et bien voilà un
lourd total un plusieurs centaines de
blessés du côté des forces de l'ordre et
des manifestants également des centaines
de personnes interpellées et la presse
régionale qui se également ce que va
devenir la mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites après le 1er mai
oui c'est la question que se pose le
journal l'Alsace à saün était un bouquet
final pour l'intersydical se demande le
bien public elle est syndicats vont-ils
rester unis face au gouvernement comment
ça a été le cas depuis janvier se
demande le journal La Provence d'autant
que les stratégies commencent à diverger
la CFDT de Laurent Berger serait plus
favorable à un retour à la table des
discussions avec le gouvernement pour
évoquer notamment le nouveau pacte de la
vie au travail que souhaite Emmanuel
Macron à l’inter syndical se réunit
aujourd'hui pour prendre une décision
sur la suite du mouvement contre la
réforme des retraites et en tout cas un
prochain rendez-vous se dessine pour les
opposants à la réforme la proposition de
loi déposée à l'Assemblée nationale par
le groupe lyode pour abroger cette
réforme des retraites elle sera débattue
le 8 juin et on finit par du foot Oriane
à la Une de La Dépêche du Midi une
dépêche du Midi consacrée à la victoire
en courbe de France du Toulouse Football
Club le TFC ce soir le Stadium de
Toulouse va fêter ses héros puisque les
Toulousains reprennent le chemin du
championnat contre Lens pas sûr que les
joueurs toulousains soient très frais
après à la fête de la victoire en Coupe
de France ce week-end ils ont été fêté
dimanche par 20 000 supporters places du
Capitole la Coupe de France que le TFC
avait gagné une seule fois c'était il y
a 66 ans très longtemps merci Alex sur
cette revue de presse la Une du Figaro
l'exécutif mis sur le dialogue social
pour sortir de la cuisine
très beau titre elle a une de Libé orage
au désespoir
c'est à dire ce matin dans l'idée et
dans le figa merci Jean-Baptiste Daoulas
merci frère d'avoir été avec nous merci
Alex merci à tous de nous avoir suivi si
vous voulez voir au revoir cette
émission vous pouvez la retrouver sur
notre nouvelle plateforme public
sénat.fr prochain rendez-vous à 18h sans
public Thomas Hugues et nous on se
retrouve demain très bonne journée
[Musique]